MBA Awards you a big fan I am a huge fan
I ever written for the Greek I'm a book
fan well from Milwaukee so we haven't
added an NBA MVP in a while so right
that's Korean I just actually saw which
was pretty cool did you meet him I did
not meet him but he is a bachelor fan
he's been on the Rachael Susan
okay who are you gonna geek out when you
get to shake their hand tonight I try
not to do you god I'm Charles Barkley
founders right there - yeah
and I try to pretend I don't care about
it inside you know you have to care a
little bit of course I gotta get your
thoughts are you watching the season of
The Bachelorette with Miss Hannah yeah I
think she's doing great
what do you think no one cares what I
think we want to know what you think you
know she's been very outspoken and she's
talked a lot about sex and religion
topics that are perhaps taboo in some
parts of the world what do you think of
her kind of taking that that Avenue I
think it's excellent I mean everyone
knows I tend to say what's on my mind I
think she's a very authentic person and
I think it's it's almost hard for her to
be inauthentic which I really enjoy
and I think it's good I mean I think the
kind of paradox of someone like Hannah
who's been outspoken about her faith
which i think is is great but also
sometimes you know that sometimes makes
us feel judged and shamed and and I
think she's been open about this and I
think she's been a role model for a lot
of young women who maybe come from a
traditional upbringing and and it's okay
to kind of liberate yourself so I think
it's great I think she's doing a
fantastic job have you reached out to
her are you she was on my podcast so I
got a chance to meet her an interview
with her and she was very open in that
episode it was I thought she was great
and vulnerable and so I really enjoyed
talking to her what surprised you most
about her it surprised me most I had
high expectations for Hannah but
she really is a lot of people like to
say mature for their age but I from what
I talked to has a really good head on
her shoulders for being 24 and I thought
that was impressive
I gotta get your thoughts on the whole
controversy with Jed and the
ex-girlfriend have you been following
this I have what are your thoughts what
the [ __ ] Chad are does the truth lie in
all of it I don't know I mean I don't I
don't have any inside information but
there seems to be some hard-hitting
evidence I've been you've been checking
out on et online.com I only get my yeah
I mean didn't you guys interview that
didn't interview did you feel that it
was authentic listen I will say that I
didn't I didn't get a chance to watch
that interview but I will said as
someone who's been on the show I have
had you know friends of friends who get
who are going through the casting
process surprisingly asked my opinion
about going through it who admit that
they're actually ating someone and and
toy with the concept of doing what what
Jed did and I it is surprising to me I
sometimes wonder if you know past few
years with the rise of social media for
all the the criticism that people over
the years have gotten for right reasons
I think it's I think it's a little bit
more justified these days because people
I mean that's not the first time
someone's done this but it's pretty
aggressive I don't know if you've seen
tonight's episode there is there's not
an episode that Jed's in without a
guitar or a piano it's like it's almost
like the perfect episode you've already
seen tonight's episode
you get screeners I I have a podcast and
a great relationship with the franchise
and someone who is the bachelor okay but
yeah I'm uh it's disappointing and I
hope for Honus well I mean I don't know
actually what happened so but if he's
going far yeah so you know that it's
Mike I mean it seems like it I have no
inside information but as
as a viewer it seems like he's a
front-runner don't you think I do I do
so I would assume he's top four their
connection is very palpable I do want to
ask you about a friend of yours Dean
angler he revealed he's living in a van
okay so what's it like how's he doing I
don't think it'll last it's a van but
he's free-spirited he seems to be you
know really yearning for this sort of
adventure spirited in the sense that
he's the type of guy who would try to
live in a van are you gonna join him at
all no no I haven't seen it I mean I
don't know what's in there a bed and I
think a TV Hey I mean listen Dean is
he's a great guy he's a very interesting
guy and he sounds like he was raised in
a situation where he had a kind of a
lifestyle that was conducive to that so
I give him a lot of prop I will say this
about Dean he he is his own person and
he's comfortable in his own skin to be
that person when he could easily be
intimidated to do that so I give him
props so you know what the plan is is it
just to drive and Leslie or is there a
routine in the world I mean I wish I had
that type of independence that Dean has
sometimes but I think he's just gonna
he'll probably do it for the summer and
then probably give up I think I'm just
going to travel yeah speaking of
independence are you an independent man
are you a single man what's the the
latest with your relationship status I
am single my I had a hot date lined up
and then she booked a gig and couldn't
come so I brought my buddy who was your
hot date okay
do we know her she an actor a singer a
little something something she couldn't
make it so what's what's the latest with
you just I am doing some acting I have a
show coming out called the coop it's a
Funny or Die production I'm not sure
when it comes out I think that sometimes
this year with my girl Katie keyphrase
yeah and my podcast bio files and then
my essential he'll come but he keeps me
real busy with natural habits so I've
been staying busy it's going really well
and you know
just trying to keep my head on my
shoulders
[Applause]
[Music]